let me bring you some breaking news an
al jazeera correspondent has been shot
by israeli forces we understand that
she's been killed sharing abu akhlah was
working in palestine she was a veteran
correspondent for many years we
understand it's happened in jeanine in
the occupied west bank let's go to nida
ibrahim who's joining us on the phone
anita what more can you tell us
what we known for now
is the palestinian health ministry has
announced her death
has been covering uh the events
unfolding in janine specifically an
israeli raid
to the city in the north of the occupied
west bank which she was hit
by a bullet to the head she was
transferred to the hospital
our colleague and producer rania has
been in touch with the hospital before
the announcement of the death the
medical team called her that she had a
very very slim chance
and unfortunately we just got the news
from the palestinian
health ministry announcing
her death as you can imagine this is
it's given a shock
to
the journalists who are who have been
working with her she's a very well
respected journalist
she's been
covering the palestinian story for years
and years now
since the um
she has joined the algebra since the
beginning of the second into harder
she's been covering on the news
and we are now
very shocked very sad but
this is the reality of
palestinian journalists covering the
news that
unfortunately they find themselves part
of the story
nida i understand of course that this is
forgive me for interrupting you neither
but i do of course understand we all do
understand that this is a very difficult
moment for you and the team there are
you able to tell us any more about the
circumstances under which this happened
to be honest rob
i've seen a few videos i couldn't
continue watching them as you can
imagine this is difficult
i've seen
her shot
in the head that's all i've seen as
another circumstances i'm not sure where
she was standing at the time
we're trying to uh leave
did you hear now to climb and cover from
there but unfortunately what we know at
the moment is
very different
the circumstances under which events
like this have happened before um do
that do we know what the procedure will
be from say the israeli forces or the
palestinian organizations will there be
some sort of investigation
and it happens with a lot of
palestinians
journalists are not journalists the
israeli army often announces
that it's investigating that it's
looking into stories but as many
palestinians will tell you that
unless it's not all deaths in the
palestinian authority by the uh israeli
forces fire go unindicted
that they believe palestinians believe
that
people are not going to be
housed accountable for what's going on
it's
it's not something that is limited to
journalists
to palestinians
i'm sorry i'm just out of words but
there's
nothing that palestinians believe
will provide justice
to them in these cases
nida if you can bring us up to date with
the situation that has been going on
between israel and palestinians in the
last few weeks particularly of course
for viewers who are just joining us and
may not be aware of what's been
happening
so jimmy
has been
the epicenter of the current palace
israeli escalation
it has intensified the israeli where you
have intensified
recently
on jeanine
the occupied west bank after a series of
attacks that have targeted israelis
inside israel
and
in some illegal israeli settlements
across the occupied west bank
but
the israeli escalation
has been
ongoing for years the israeli raids the
killing of palestinian
young men and women
by israeli forces or by israeli settlers
living in the west bank so this is not
something that has been limited to just
the past few weeks
but we've been seeing more and more
palestinians in the jeannine area
carrying weapon
weapons saying that they want to fight
the israeli army when they read the
cities
of janine so we often
see armed clashes uh in suit between the
palestinian fighters and the israeli
army
so
if
so the place where
the escalation has been intensifying
is the genuine area and we've been
speaking to a lot of young palestinians
there who are saying that
they don't believe
that they have hope for a political
horizon for a future and this is why
they're fighting israel they're telling
us that this is
the only option that israel has left
with and
sharing has been covering extensively
on that story we've been um
meeting with her during our coverage in
jeanine
even just yesterday she
commented on a picture of us and said
come to janine
cover with us so
i i
it's
it's just
where to escape me
[Applause]
neither just stay with me for a second i
just want to inform viewers who may just
be uh joining us that we are getting
reports that an al jazeera correspondent
sharing about who's working in palestine
in jeanine in the occupied west bank has
been killed after being shot by israeli
forces
nida just give us some indication if you
can of the kind of conditions that
journalists covering the situation are
facing on a regular basis
so it's important
to highlight that palestinian
journalists are not only shot or hit
because they're just there
they are often targeted and we see it
when we come to protest or when we go to
places
that sometimes the israeli army
specifically shoots at journalists
because
part of what we do is uncover
the crimes or the attack
or
whatever the israeli army doesn't want
to be put out
on air so
when you talk to lots of palestinian
journalists they they would show you
injuries they'll show you
where they've been shot
will be for the fire or by
illegal israeli settlers so
the circumstances that palestinian
journalists are living under
are not so different from the rest of
their people and remember the
palestinians are covering a story that
is theirs that is very personal to them
and this is sometimes we cover a story
that we know the person who was shot and
killed
so they are part of the story and they
are part of
unfolding and
uncovering
what is happening in the occupied
territory
nida is there any effort
that can be made by
on behalf on by organizations on behalf
of palestinian journalists who are
covering this situation to try to
protect them or is there a limit to what
can be done
that's the thing you were talking about
a powerful
uh
military
occupation that has been targeted in
journalism
for years
so
it's important
to talk about the story it's important
to keep highlighting those violations
but as long as
you don't see
people or soldiers or purposes being
brought to justice for what they do
we're not looking at an end to this
series of
killing journalists
or or them being shocked by them being
injured so
what's nothing is war
justice
if they want the world to know what the
israeli
government is where they're limited
to them
but
if the messenger is being shot
you can imagine
the situation of the rest
of the people
nida thank you very much stay with me
please we've just been watching pictures
of shireen
reporting from
palestine and other parts of the area as
you've been talking for viewers who are
just joining us we're getting reports
that al jazeera correspondent shelina
abraclai has been killed after being
shot by israeli forces in janine in the
occupied west bank i want to go to our
correspondent stephanie decker who has
been working in the in the west bank in
west jerusalem particularly stephanie
give us some context please clearly
this is a significant blow
to the teams who have been working
in the area you have been working there
for the last few weeks tell us your
experiences your
impressions if you like of what it's
like to be working in that environment
well i mean i haven't uh actually been
in janine in the last couple of weeks
because
our west bank correspondent
has been covering um
what's been going on there but i've been
covering this region for around 16 years
so
you know we're well versed in in how
these things go and um in terms of
context there have been
uh israeli army raids on the janine
refugee camp it's an area uh where you
do have and you know the west bank you
don't usually see guns on the streets in
the in this area
does have you know armed men so this is
what the army has been doing um in the
last couple of weeks particularly may
also
um targeting what it says were men and
uh people involved with
men who carried out attacks inside
israel also last thursday
you had an attack
from two men who came from not
particularly gene but
but from romana which is a village close
to janine they carried out an attack in
the central city of
elad so uh the army and in recent days
the israeli media and the establishment
here have been talking about
another major clampdown if you will in
janine they've been
weighing up two options
uh with the military advisors whether
gene or gaza because
they wanted to respond to what you've
had like now six or seven attacks within
israel having said all that
the security establishment here has
maintained that these attacks
are carried out by individuals not
particularly
have any
group backing factional backing if you
will
but you have had an increased rhetoric
from palestinian islamic jihad also
hamas
and you do have elements
of these in the camp but of course you
know going back to operating as a
journalist particularly in the occupied
west bank during these kinds of raids
um it's very difficult and
you know as you heard me say that
people we wear press vests uh clearly
marked
um and the teams have been there and
this this morning was a raid
that has been carried they have been
carrying out these out this was a major
major operation in the sense of what i
just described she has been debated here
whether that's going to start so it's um
it's tragic
i think we're all still in in disbelief
you said of right to the side that
you've been covering the region for
about 16 years
is it your impression that there is uh
that palestinian journalists who are
covering this conflict are treated or
regarded differently by the israeli
forces
to in comparison to say journalists who
are moved in from other areas to cover
the conflict or is there a
are all journalists
essentially regarded in a particular way
by israeli forces
i think you make a valid point i think
for sure i think there is a uh
you know how would i describe it
hierarchy perhaps i mean yes old
journalists can be targeted by israeli
forces but certainly
it's absolutely valid to say palestinian
journalists who
as nidalta says this is their lives
right this is their story they're
covering their backyard they're covering
something that happens to them and their
people um it's very different and yes
there seems to be more of um of uh uh
how would i say open
you know open book when it comes to
targeting them or and there's little
accountability you know whether it's a
protest whether it's
you know rage like this
um there doesn't there isn't an element
of let's say journalistic um
that you don't don't touch journalists
because they're there the israeli army
and the israeli border police will very
often target journalists to you know to
disperse them i mean i've been part of
that and again i'm a foreign journalist
you know i've been coming here for years
but i come in and out um
and i think there is an element of
discrepancy about whether you're a
palestinian journalist or you're a
foreign journalist but at the same time
you know they do hit anyone i mean gaza
border protests you know they would
chase us down with a with a tear gas
drone actively
we'd actually run away from the drone
which would follow you i've had
colleagues have tear gas drop on their
heads because they weren't aware it was
hovering
above them a journalist can be shot at
journalists can be targeted with you
know uh
today tragically it's live fire but you
know tear gas canisters sun grenades uh
you know these sort of sponge bullets
they use but that can really maim in
india too yes absolutely um particularly
you know when you're all gathered in a
certain area so this is something that
is not new um it's it's not surprising
the the outcome is tragically
unnecessary what has happened today with
shireen i think everyone is just like
why you know why why has this happened
there was no reason for have to happen
um
so so yes uh yes he's really i mean i
and i i we haven't had a response yet
uh but this is something that
you know uh like mizah said there's
there's very little accountability but
this is
this is the tragedy on a scale that uh
you know i i i don't know but yes in my
experience absolutely the the military
targets the vertically target
and more so uh more so palestinian
journalists absolutely i think that's a
very valid valid uh
kind of statement staff stay with me for
a second i just want to tell viewers who
are just joining us that uh we're
getting reports that an al jazeera
correspondent shalina barclay who's
working in jeanine in the occupied west
bank
has died after being shot by israeli
forces
details are still fairly scarce as you
can imagine at the moment we're talking
to our correspondents nida ibrahim and
stephanie decker who've been working in
the region um stephanie with regards to
what nida had referred to in terms of a
follow-up to this in terms of an
investigation she was giving me the
impression that there wasn't a lot of
confidence that there would be
accountability at the end of this what
is your interpretation as somebody who's
covered the region for 16 years um
and has seen events like this in the
past what's your interpretation of what
the process is likely to be
well i think you know what what is what
is accountability for someone who's lost
their life right what is the
accountability for the family like is it
an apology is it you know i i i don't i
don't see how any of that
um i mean if i look at if we look at
facts on the ground
no journalists have been killed in the
past many years ago you had a british
activist rachel carr she was killed by
the army many many years ago and there's
an investigation you know what is the
accountability i think what journalists
want is for them the methods of
operating to change is for them to be
safe to be able to do their job uh to be
able to to be
in you know a relatively safe of course
when there's
military confrontations things are tense
i mean we know this and and journalists
you know you take measured risks on the
ground and particularly here
you know when if you are palestinian
journalist or you've been coming here
for years you understand a bit of the
language of the ground
you know how to operate you know that
you stay behind certain areas that you
don't go in the middle of a you know of
an active like we know these things but
of course you know things on the ground
change and they change very quickly and
i think at the end of the day what
people want what accountability should
be is that you know
journalists should not be actively
targeted uh it's as simple as that uh
you know we should be able to do our job
the problem is these days it sounds like
a simple request but it's it's
it's not it's not anymore you are
actively targeted because you are a
journalist without mention there you
know they don't want you to see things
they don't want you to cover something
so you know so they will they will try
to disperse you whether that is with
whatever means they use the probably
mean
is that it's an extra level
of of dangerous because
you have the army there it is tense you
have armed men in the camps which is
what the army is clamping down on so you
start having you know what are almost
like many pockets of active warfare um
and i don't know the exact details of
today but certainly the initial report
is that they were shot at uh by the army
wearing press vests
um i i don't know any more details than
that
but
you know accountability i i don't see
what could be accountable you know what
could like is it an apology is there
going to be investigation are they not
this is just the way unfortunately that
things go on the ground here and
and accountability is is rare uh
you know i don't see
what could you know what could come out
of this that you know what are they
going to say they made a mistake
at this point you know should he have
gone
it's um
yeah
and at the end of the day the journal
should not be targeted uh and and i
don't think that's going to change
stephanie for now thank you very much
indeed we've just been seeing pictures
as you've been talking of shireen uh
doing her work in in the area i want to
bring in uh again nida ibrahim now nida
i understand of course that you and the
team have been working very closely with
shireen abu akley
tell me if you can
um how this it will affect the way that
you choose to cover the situation uh in
between israel and palestine if indeed
it will affect it at all how do you make
a decision to go forward after an
incident like this
please forgive me for interrupting you
because unfortunately the signal that
we're getting at the moment is not a
clear one i want to go back to to
stephanie decker i want to to steph to
ask you the same question clearly this
is a significant but it is always a blow
when somebody dies under any
circumstances in any sort of conflict
but
when it comes to being a journalist
how do you move forward how do the teams
move forward from this what's the
process do you do you stock uh take
stock and do you rethink the way that
you cover
a situation like this
i think i i don't think it's going to
change how we operate i think this is
not going to make us stop uh covering
these kinds of things again like i don't
know the exact details of of how this
happened
but you know we like i said you know we
we take measured risks
and uh and often you know people even at
headquarters don't even know what what
that what that's involved you know
beyond the ground things change
constantly um
and and we try and just understand the
ground and read the ground and stay
within
you know within a measured
hot safe area of operating to be able to
cover something but like as anything on
the ground you know
things are fine until they're not and
that happens immediately and that's just
something that we're also aware of and
you try to measure that as as
you know as well as you can and of
course you know this is this is also a
story whether it's here whether it's
somewhere else you know to understand
the ground is important and palestinian
journalists of course know the ground
this is their home this is you know like
my dad was saying they've been covering
the success shireen she's been sleeping
there you know they've been staying
there they know the ground they know the
streets they have contacts they they
you couldn't be
um how should i say you couldn't be
better prepared than they are it's not a
foreign team that has never been there
that have flown in you know that have
been there a week no you are talking
about
veteran journalists palestinian
journalists from the area who have been
there years in years out who've covered
the stories of live destroyers below the
ground who know how to operate um
and this is i think is the lesson out of
this right it's like it's not
uh
gung-ho people who don't understand no
these are people who
couldn't know the story better
and the ground better
and this is and this is what's
tragically happened i don't think it's
going to change the way we operate um
but it highlights just how difficult i
think it is for germans to do their job
and again like i don't know the details
exactly of how this happened today it is
of course a tense area you have
palestinian gunmen you have the israeli
military it is tense um there is my fire
from what i understood there was an
exchange of fire also with
with with gunmen in the camp with the
army so again i don't know all the
specifics but
you know it's one of those things this
is this is a veteran team this is a team
that's been cut they're from
you know the occupied west bank it's
coveraging him extensively
they couldn't have been better informed
in terms of how to operate on the ground
stephanie for now thank you very much
indeed